it's a meat only diet yeah yeah but i
went down i did like paleo
and then that worked really really well
a very restricted paleo and then i
and then it stopped working and then it
was meat and greens and then it was meat
and then i've been on meat for three and
a half years
and i'm just i'm getting better now
would you consider adding things back
slowly to try to see which elements you
could safely add
that's the goal i mean i counsel people
kind of on facebook for free
and it's not medical advice people on
this diet and i've seen a lot of success
with reintroducing foods so it seems to
have a component of gut healing
and then when that happens like a lot of
these people have been on a ton of
medication for a really long time and
then they reduce their diet they go to
all meat
and then a lot of these people
especially if they're not as sick as me
go on to reintroduce things and don't
have symptoms
usually they stay without you know
grains and kind of
keep to paleo if they have sicknesses
but the goal is
not to be restricted like this forever